[Music]
right the Boas over on they have been
put on notice America will no longer be
bowing down to their empty threats and
their aggressive tactics the days of
blindly trusting and trying to bribe
this rogue regime are now over because
hours ago President Trump made the
courageous decision to pull the United
States out of this very flawed Iranian
nuclear agreement let's take a look the
Iranian regime is the leading state
sponsor of terror the deal allowed or
rent to continue enriching uranium and
overtime reach the brink of a nuclear
breakout this disastrous deal gave this
regime and its a regime of great terror
many billions of dollars some of it in
actual cash today we have definitive
proof that this Iranian promise was a
lie therefore I am announcing today that
the United States will withdraw from the
Iran nuclear deal thank God now
naturally the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani he responded with a threat
saying that his rogue regime they're
ready to start enriching an unlimited
amount of uranium
if secondary negotiations with Europe do
not yield positive results
now this hollow extortion may have
worked with Obama but not any more
this is a new age of diplomacy based on
the concept that Reagan taught us peace
through strength
it works watch this as we exit the Iran
deal we will be working with our allies
to find a real comprehensive and lasting
solution to the Iranian nuclear threat
in the meantime powerful sanctions will
go into full effect if the regime
continues its nuclear aspirations it
will have bigger problems than it has
ever had before
now of course if Iran if they're serious
about making the world a better place
ending their nuclear ambitions and
immediately halting their efforts
destroy the United States and Israel
well there would be still time to
negotiate most US sanctions will not be
reinstated for another 90 days oil
related sanctions will take 180 days to
come online but let's be clear
presidents from is willing and ready to
negotiate just like he is with little
rocket man take a look
fact is they are going to want to make a
new and lasting deal one that benefits
all of Iran and the Iranian people when
they do I am ready willing and able
great things can happen for Iran and
great things can happen for the peace
and stability that we all want in the
Middle East all right it's really simple
if Iran wants its people to prosper
without the burden of US sanctions they
just have to come to the table now the
leaders of Iran they are corrupt they
are immoral they are radical this is a
rogue theocracy and they're suffering
people need better here's what President
Trump had to say about that very subject
also earlier today in this historic
speech I want to deliver a message to
the long-suffering people of Iran the
people of America stand with you it has
now been almost 40 years since this
dictatorship seized power and took a
proud nation hostage most of Iran's 80
million citizens have sadly never known
an Iran that prospered in peace with its
neighbors and commanded the admiration
of the world and as you could imagine
many prominent Democrats they are
slamming the president's decision
including John Kerry he of course has
been busy trying to undermine the Trump
administration by conducting potentially
illegal shadow diplomacy he said the
Iran deal made our ally safer well
meanwhile President Obama released a
incredibly boring lengthy long-winded
holier-than-thou sanctimonious statement
calling the president's decision
misguided will spare you all those
boring details this country does not
need diplomatic input from a president
who
saw the collapse of the Middle East the
unfettered expansion of Russian
aggression and a situation on the Korean
Peninsula that was totally out of
control oh and he gave them a hundred
and fifty billion and of course what
Democrats are complaining America's
closest ally in the Middle East Israel
is under a daily imminent threat from
Iran they are applauding the president's
decision here's what the Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu had to say
about the president Israel fully
supports president Trump's full decision
today
to reject the disastrous nuclear deal
with the terrorist regime in Tehran his
world has opposed the nuclear deal from
the start because we said that rather
than blocking Iran's path to a bomb the
deal actually paves Iran's path to an
entire arsenal of nuclear bombs and this
within a few years time Israel thinks
the president Trump did an historic move
and this is what Israel thanks president
Trump for his courageous leadership his
commitment to confront the terrorist
regime in Tehran and his commitment to
ensure that Iran never gets nuclear
weapons not today not in a decade it was
just last week the Prime Minister
Netanyahu who revealed Iran secret
nuclear program and its continued desire
to develop a weapon system that it's
capable of delivering nuclear warheads
still way before Netanyahu went public
with this intelligence President Trump
had long promised to scrap what a
terrible deal he inherited he kept his
promise watch this my number one
priority is to dismantle the disastrous
deal with Iran I have been in business a
long time
I know deal-making and let me tell you
steel is catastrophic for America for
Israel and for the whole of the Middle
East this was just prior to the signing
of the Iran deal which gave back to Iran
150 billion dollars and gave us
absolutely nothing it will go down in
history as one of the worst deals ever
negotiated never ever ever in my life
have I seen any transaction so
incompetently negotiated as our deal
with Iran and I mean never now tonight
the president is fulfilling that very
important campaign promise after years
of bowing down to dictators kissing the
rings of despot
America is once again leading on the
world stage peace through strength this
is so important because if history has
taught us anything it is that
appeasement never works
you may remember Neville Chamberlain he
was the British prime minister declared
peace in our time
after caving in during negotiations
after meeting Hitler in Munich take a
look the settlement of the
Czechoslovakian problem
which has now been achieved is in my
view only the prelude to a larger
settlement in which all Europe may find
peace compare that to the great Winston
Churchill he vowed to win at all costs
he led with strength he triumphed over
evil in his time I would say to the
house and I said to those who have
joined the government I have nothing to
offer but blood toil tears and rich he
wants what is our policy I will say it
is to wage war by de lanzadera
with all our might with all the strength
that God can give us to wage war against
the monstrous tyranny never surpassed in
the dark and lamentable catalogue of
human crime you are what is our aim
I can onl say in one word victory
victory at all costs
victory in spite of all Kara victory
however long and hard the road may be
but without victory there is no survival
what an incredible order and remember
during the bombing of Britain he went
out amongst the people the entire time
every day then of course you have former
President Bill Clinton remember when he
promised you that appeasing North Korea
bribing them would prevent them from
getting nuclear weapons here's what he
promised the American people this is a
good deal for the United States North
Korea will freeze and then dismantle its
nuclear program South Korea and our
other allies will be better protected
the entire world will be safer as we
slow the spread of nuclear weapons of
course that deal we now know is an utter
and complete failure it gave North Korea
covered a successfully developed their
nuclear weapons now compare that to
President Ronald Reagan he called the
Soviet Union an evil empire he demanded
that Berlin Wall come down without
concessions from the West's own advisers
said don't do this he did it anyway take
a look there is one sign
the Soviets can make that would be
unmistakable that would advance
dramatically dramatically the cause of
freedom and peace general secretary
Gorbachev if you seek peace if you seek
prosperity for the Soviet Union and
Eastern Europe if you seek
liberalization come here to this gate
mr. Gorbachev open this gate mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall and the
wall came down indeed the Soviet Union
collapsed the cold war effectively ended
sadly all of what we just showed you was
lost on President Obama he went out of
his way to appease the mullahs in Iran
sending them boatloads of cash and other
currency in what was in exchange for a
simple unverifiable promise oh and they
continued to spin their centrifuges
remember this today after two years of
negotiations the United States together
our international partners has achieved
something that decades of animosity has
not a comprehensive long-term deal with
Iran that will prevent it from obtaining
a nuclear weapon this deal demonstrates
that American diplomacy can bring about
real and meaningful change change that
makes our country and the world safer
and more secure this deal is also in
line with a tradition of American
leadership it's very simple appeasement
never works sucking up to dictators
doesn't work only peace through strength
will work now this is playing out right
before our eyes on the Korean Peninsula
under presidents from the United States
sharpen their sanctions they sent
multiple Carrier Strike groups to the
area they pressured North Korea's most
important ally China and the president
ramped up his rhetoric even calling Kim
jong-un little rocket man
now tonight the United States and the
world is closer than it has ever been to
achieving peace on the peninsula and the
nuclearization of North Korea secretary
Pompeo just arrived in North Korea where
he will be conducting a series of
negotiations ahead of the president's
upcoming
we're gonna bring you any updates from
these crucial talks as we get them
alright but first we have some new
developments from the deep state
according to a brand-new CBS News poll
more Americans now think rightly so
Robert Muller's witch hunt is in fact
politically motivated now this comes as
the mainstream destroyed Trump media
continues to do Muller's bidding
according to News Buster's get this CBS
NBC NBC spent a combined 30 seconds on
the recent beatdown last Friday of the
Special Counsel investigation from a
federal judge and meanwhile President
Trump's poll numbers they're rising this
despite a news Buster study showing that
network news broadcasts in this country
featured negative stories about the
president 90 percent of the time
Wow and I've told you journalism's dead
and breaking tonight the Senate Intel
committee they released its first report
on Russia election interference the big
takeaway the committee is now confirming
no votes were changed by Russia during
the 2016 presidential election we'll
continue to follow that story and
meanwhile the deep states popularity is
waning Trump's popularity is soaring
even more lawmakers and out pushing the
Department of Justice to stop
obstructing Congress and comply with the
rule of law the House Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy House Majority Whip Steve
Scalise they are now inching closer to
holding sessions in contempt of Congress
over the slow walk of the subpoenaed
documents and the redactions and of
course the claims of national security
that turned out not to be true
Scalise will join us in a few minutes
but first Judicial Watch
tonight has announced the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein he may
release previously redacted portions of
the memo outlining the scope of the
Muller investigation finally all right
also tonight this is important I want to
address the so-called firestorm
surrounding the president's pick to lead
the CIA tomorrow Jena Haspel she is set
to appear before the Senate for what
will likely be a pretty contentious
confirmation hearing Democrats the media
and anyone who generally hates Donald
Trump have been trashing this career CIA
official slamming her
treatment of terrorists after 9/11 when
we lost nearly 3,000 Americans and some
alleging she was way too tough with some
of the world's most notorious killers I
have said it before she in a Haspel and
many people who worked with her and work
with her for decades guess what they say
she is without a doubt an American Hero
she is smart she is diligence she is
brave and most importantly her actions
in the wake of 9/11 kept this country
safe and brought justice to those people
those terrorists look at her sama bin
Laden he's at the bottom of the sea in
part because of the work like Gena has
spell remember top CIA official Jose
Rodriguez right here on this program
told us that the enhanced interrogation
programs that has faux conducted were
vital to America's war on terror it led
to the courier which led to bin Laden
watch this so in other words you're
saying that the accusation that these
enhanced interrogation techniques were
used beyond what we had already would
already been disclosed you're saying is
false number one and that in spite of
their suggestion that they were not
successful you're saying that in fact
that's not true you were there it was
successful it was very successful and
for those of us who were there it is
just amazing that they could have come
to this conclusion those of us who read
the intelligence coming out of our black
sites every morning and who acted on
that intelligence know the value and
basically it led to the destruction of
the organization I know I looked a lot
younger there but the point is taken the
Senate needs to put politics aside
confirm Haspel as soon as possible